all the lonely Starbucks lovers they'll  tell you I'm insane  [Music]  fault and loud and everybody shots turn  down for what  [Music]  this girl's a lawyer a lawyer yeah  counterpart they make a lot of money  smart and pretty you should go for it oh  well who sings that song uh Chris Brown  yeah that's definitely misheard no songs  about respecting women that fighter yeah  that's not a Chris Brown so I think I  know guys round all of me  just like animals animals like  animals-mals  [Music]  I'm a dragon that's right love ya i'm  gonna love ya i'm gonna love ya like a  black widow baby  Oh become Who I am I really obvious see  how that's a really oh yeah that's a  good mr. Cleary ya know those are the  real works I'll be drinking bobbins you  can flip independence Gotti well that  doesn't make any grammatical sense at  all I mean it's the song so I mean huh  that's stupid